how much time has passed from the time
on the left to the time on the right so
we have a clock on the left and a clock
on the right with different times shown
and we want to know how much time has
passed since the clock said read this
first time till it read the second time
we're also told the time passed is less
than 12 hours
that's helpful that means we know that
this first clock wasn't say sometime on
monday and the second one was sometime
on wednesday and these hands have been
going around and around we know the time
past is less than 12 hours
so the first thing i think we should do
to figure out the difference in these
times is to figure out what are these
times let's read these clocks
over here on the left
looking at our hour hand first
it's between six and seven
so the hour hand starts at the top and
it's gone past six o'clock but it's not
quite to seven
so it's six something could be 6 15 6
20. we'll figure out the minutes next
but we know it's some amount of minutes
after six but not yet seven
and now let's look at those minutes the
minute hand again started at the top
it's gone five minutes 10 15 20 25 30 35
40.
can't go to 45 here so we got to count
by ones 41 42 43
it is 43 minutes
after six o'clock or 6 43 on the left
on the right our hour hand is just after
the nine so it's soon after nine o'clock
but it's definitely not to 10 yet
and then our minute hand
right here
start the top and it's 5 10 11 minutes
after the hour
on the right so the clock on the right
is 9 11.
and now what we want to know is how long
does it take to get from this first time
6 43
all the way to the second time which is
9 11.
one way we could figure this out is to
break it into little parts let's first
let's first just see how long does it
take to get to seven o'clock
so on this first clock as soon as the
minute hand gets up to the top it'll be
seven o'clock let's see how long is that
from here where it is it has two more
minutes
to get to the nine
and then from there it has five ten
fifteen more minutes to get all the way
to the top of the clock
so until seven o'clock will be two
minutes plus fifteen more minutes
or we can write that as
minutes
then from seven let's stick with the
hours for a second let's just get from
seven to nine o'clock
so from seven to nine at seven o'clock
the hand is at the top it'll go all the
way around one hour to be eight o'clock
all the way around another hour to be
nine o'clock so that's a total from
seven to nine
of two
hours
and then finally from nine until 11
minutes after nine
the minute hand will be at the top and
it'll go 5 10 11 minutes
so this will be 11 more
minutes
so in total
from 6 43 all the way to 9 11
is 17 minutes plus 2 more hours plus 11
minutes
so we can write that that's going to be
two hours
and then we can combine our minutes
17 and 11 17 and 11
that will be eight ones a 10 and a 10 is
20 so 28
minutes
it takes two hours
and 28 minutes for the clock to go from
6 43 this time on the left until 9 11
the time on the right